what are some of the good southern foods
we don't know about other maybe they're
chains maybe they're not maybe it's
places that are uh specific to you you
know what I miss yeah from back home
what do you know about Brahms very
little but I know let me tell you right
now is it a custard yeah yeah is it is I
know it's ice cream
I believe it's a soft serve they have a
soft serve and they have regular ice
cream okay their burgers are bomb
you see is it is it custard I'm almost
are you a custard gal I like an Andes
custard I do like you like Andy's
custard I do
yeah did I just fall in love with my
twin yeah I do twin brother
what kind of bra oh
okay so Brahms Brahms is interesting oh
I miss it I miss Brahms I think it
started in Oklahoma maybe or yeah I
think it did you know what it is it's
just a good burger yes oh and I'm not a
burger fan I'd rather have a taco I'd
rather have pizza everything but when it
comes to a Braum's burger oh you can't
go wrong yeah you can't go wrong
interesting we love me and Ben there's a
place in Montauk New York out on Long
Island the furthest point is called
John's and they have amazing Burgers
it's like what Shake Shack should have
been and they serve them on potato buns
and they're so good and they have fresh
ice cream like you know strawberry Oreo
ice cream and coffee oreo and John's
Driving in Montauk New York that's
that's our spot we love those oh yeah
like that it's old school and it's just
you know it's really really cool places
like that in the summer there's nothing
better in the summer than getting a
custard getting a burger sitting outside
you know
could it get a little bit more pixelated
though yeah I mean you know if we ask
Ben to work you know him and his wife
will sue me
so I have to re although Ben go down you
know there is a nice one go to the left
see that sunset hit that one yeah
Montauk has some of the best sunsets in
the country and it's uh well I'm just
saying if you're out there but so Brahms
now Libby Higgins do you have a a
restaurant a place where you would go
and cry where would you go what would
you like in the whole country I loved
you know what I used to love in when I
was a little kid I was an actor I don't
know if you know this but no from that
when I was six years old to 12 I was on
Sesame Street multiple times I was in
some NYU student films and I auditioned
for a lot of things that I never I never
booked right and I would kind of go home
sad you know my parents would take me
out of school my mother would bring me
into the city I'd do an audition I'd
flub it I'd [ __ ] it up and then I'd come
back to the Penn Station Dairy Queen and
I would buy a blizzard and sometimes I
would sit in the chair and kind of cry
into the blizzard while I ate it and
then one time uh I I got something thing
I was trying to explain to him and he
did he made the wrong thing and a sweet
Indian man who probably just got to
America he made the wrong thing and I
lost my mind
and I started screaming and I took it
and I threw it in the garbage but I
missed because I'm a [ __ ] so it hit and
it splattered everywhere and I was
screaming no
no and I threw it and the Indian guy
um was started like laughing she didn't
know what to do and I just like screamed
it and then I
I I just looked and my my grandmother
was with me and she goes come on and she
was like so she goes I'm ashamed of you
she goes I'm ashamed of you
I'm I remember her said that she just
kept saying that I'm ashamed of you I'm
ashamed of you and then we went to the
Long Island Railroad waiting room and I
just sat there and I still had like
blizzard kind of all over myself and I
just sat there in tears where was that
place for you
is that for you did you ever that where
was that for you
a super sandwich shop is what it was
called in St Louis take me there Libby
very small Diner right I love it the
super sandwich super sandwich shop or
sandwich or soup super sandwich super
sandwich shop take us there let me
Higgins it was uh uh only you can only
sit at a counter thank you so much ben
he saw that I was struggling and rushed
well if he had set the mic up in the
beginning I couldn't get any more if he
had set the mic up in the beginning
you'd be fine but Ben likes to like his
boss likes to do it on the Fly we don't
love prep
he's really struggling though thank you
what a this guy is just the sweetest
little angel you know everyone says that
who doesn't know him okay
he hurt himself
super sandwich shop in St Louis on St
Louis Avenue you can only sit at the
counter my father would take me there a
lot and we got to see him on Wednesday
nights because they were divorced
and Wednesday was his day Wednesday was
his day so and how many of you would he
take to the uh super sandwich shop uh
four of us that's a lot of counter space
my sister my little brother and my older
brother everybody in the counter seat
everybody in the counter seat Christ
Almighty
and um so then we'd stop at the liquor
store to get snacks oh he'd have a
little he'd want a couple of nips he
he'd get snacks for us we get a honey
bun or whatever but he'd get his snacks
he'd get his snacks usually a bush beer
a little warmth and uh we'd head on home
to his house where we'd watch TV what
would you watch Like The Cosby Show
Family Ties you know I'm older so these
programs were still okay I used to watch
them why aren't they okay now because
Bill Cosby went on a few bad dates
uh I'm sorry my headphone was not
working
hello the super sandwich shop in St
Louis were you able to find a picture of
it
um well he's not even look why would he
look I mean he's not even looking what
was the name of it
nine times in St Louis you said at night
it's no longer there but I'm telling you
okay but find a good pixelated photo of
it get an old pixelated photo okay what
does that say right here
the Higgins family was a family again
Wednesday nights gather your brothers
and sisters around we're getting honey
buns in a bush beer and we're going down
to the super sandwich shop because
everything's gonna be okay and then
we're gonna watch uh Bill Cosby and
everything was okay right we love to
watch Knight Rider too that was another
great program Legendary Legendary
program
and then my dad would drive us home in
his uh little station wagon and um
we'd continue on life the next day it's
a real Tracy Chapman song
you gotta fast car he actually has I got
a sandwich shop he had a car called La
Car LA carre from where that's what it
was called l e space c-a-r that was the
brand that was I think it was a null the
model the car there it is
oh my God that's like a joke y'all all
fit in there I would yes we weren't
always huge we were small who makes that
isn't it
Renault yes I didn't want to try to say
it again I mean this is like never heard
of that and I would sit in that car
screen again Ben hours and pretend I was
driving what color it was white
yep
wow wow I would just sit at it for hours
and shift the gears it was not on I'd
push in the clutch when you were little
yep pretending I was driving yeah wow
yeah so uh good times like when I got
older I switched up to a
um a writing is your father's still with
us no he has passed on okay well that's
sad because you know it's
always sad when people leave but also
now you're doing great and it would be
oh he would love it he would love it he
would love it you painted a nice picture
I felt like I was there
there's something
deeply poetic about
the times in life
where
you're making the best
of a situation that is not optimal
you know and in that time you're doing
what you can to get through
and it's very very there's something
evenly look back on it there's something
nice about it even though there's
probably some
pain associated with it because I hear
it and it sounds horrible oh there's
lots of pain it sounds horrible to me
like the idea of it is horrible and the
reality of it is even worse but but
then I I think back and I go you know
what you probably have some laughs
that's fun
you're making the best of it and that's
what life is really we also didn't have
a choice when you're a kid it's like you
just had to go wherever but he took you
I'm going over here okay that's a great
point I want to get molested by my
brother okay let's do this it is what it
is right
TGIF Thank God It's Friday huh
molesting and then Super sandwich shop
you know thank God it's Friday the super
sandwich shop almost made it well worth
it